In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for June 27 on which we commemorate St. Joanna the
Merbarrer.
This blessed woman was the wife of Kusa, king of Herod's steward.
After having it appears, been healed of some illness by the Lord, as was St. Mary Magdalene.
She served him along with the other holy women during the whole of his public ministry in Galilee
and Judea.
She was a witness of his life-giving passion, and on Easter morning went to the tomb with
spices together with Mary Magdalene, Mary the mother of James, and other women.
Finding it empty, the women stood in perplexity with bowed heads.
Two angels then appeared to them and said, Why seek ye the living among the dead?
And they remembered the Lord's words, saying, He must be crucified before rising again on
the third day.
They went to tell the apostles of all this, but their tale seemed to them to be nonsense,
and they did not believe them until Peter and John went there themselves.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.